okay bona fide bona fide were you from
originally where'd you grow up so really
I feel like I grew up a lot of places
but I was born in Long Beach and Lucerne
Valley I was raised a little bit of a
part of my early childhood wonderful
Jackson Alabama with my dad's side of
the family and I came back to California
when I was 15 I got pregnant so they
didn't want our last name to be you know
messed up so I got pregnant too early so
I came back to California tell me about
your family hit both your parents I
never had both of my parents always had
them separately but my mom she was in
and out of jail and my dad he was he was
out there in Alabama so who raised you
my grandmother and my dad yeah but my
dad stopped raising me when I was um I
was able to tell tale on on him you know
for me less than me and raping and
molesting me from the age of uh 9 to 15
and I was it finally able to tell
somebody I ended up getting pregnant so
what would your dad yeah sure I have a
child by my father
he's fine or he he or she is fine yes
she's fine she has their ups and downs
you know but she's not a head doesn't
have any deformities however she has
cerebral palsy mm-hmm
- you came to LA at what did you get I
came to LA back to Los Angeles at 15
uh-huh
I had got to fast out there and I was
not mine I started I started hoeing even
then uh-huh back in Alabama yeah I
started home and it's like am i growed
more to sexting away from sex you know
so it was you started at what age I'm I
started at 13 yeah yeah and so you know
a lot of people that get molested they
they run away from sex so they run away
from me and or whatnot you know that
wasn't me
I ran to it I'm not really addicted to
it but addicted to the attention from it
so yeah now now I'm out here in Los
Angeles them I still hope you're working
you figure out um I work all over I work
I didn't I didn't be in the Elvis
Presley Boulevard I've actually worked
all over I worked in Memphis Tennessee
on 9th Street I mean I worked in Oakland
on Mac Arthur and Marky you know San
Pablo Gary and Lauren in San Diego I
mean I just spent all the way around
from the from the west coast to the East
Coast
you started 13 is this all you've ever
done for money oh yeah yeah oh yeah I've
never never got a job so hold you know
I'm 38 38 yeah you're one child I have
seven kids thank you
yes I have six girls and one boy and are
you raising them all um no I don't raise
any of them my kids went to foster homes
ooh
drug addiction and yeah a part of my a
part of me being a prostitute I have
never smoked I had never dreamed I
didn't even like cigarettes you know at
the age of 22 when I got out of when I
got a California Youth Authority I went
to California Youth Authority for
attempted murder when I got out of there
you know I had made this plan when I was
in there to you know just become the
best prostitute ever you know and I had
like this business format and everything
however when I when I got out I met this
dude I fell in love with his dude so it
was awesome
at first at least I thought I was just
magically in loving and you know he left
and he went on vacation well his dad had
just got out of jail his dad was staying
with us or whatnot
and I got depressed because I was
looking at looking at some old stuff and
I realized that he had a whole nother
life and that's why he was on vacation
well anyways it's heavy towards
depression period and I started smoking
crack with his father to come about of
the depression like the first time I did
it was like oh my god I'm not calling
his home every time I think about him
back to that it it was it it was amazing
you know and then it's like the
prostitute or whatever became a whole
different field I mean it wasn't the
pimping in the hoenn
now I had hello I had a pimp-ass of hype
you know and everything that I did was
to get that you know it took me a while
to slow down you know because I had got
on heroin I had got on crystal meth I
just did did so much [ __ ] and it seemed
like every time that I started doing
good or I went to a program or something
I had this the
um this dream of becoming a truck driver
or whatever it seemed like something
will always lead me right back to
homeland even if it wasn't prostitute
even if it wasn't smoking drugs it's
like I'll start at home for a little bit
and then you know right back in there
what do you think the attraction is I
think the attraction is the attention
that I can it's amazing for somebody to
ride down the street and honk at me yeah
midnight if I got a midnight down there
and I see the traffic jam right on the
side streets just to interact with me I
mean it's it's amazing for me for a guy
to even pull up and be like oh my gosh
you got such beautiful smile or you got
such beautiful eyes or gosh are those
yours yeah just that attention to be
like man so it's a little self-esteem
boost yes it is and then I can guarantee
that I can guarantee you there's so many
girls out yes there are there's so many
guys sitting there in cars right they
don't have to stop - at me you know some
of the girls come out there just to get
the self-esteem boost it seems yeah
maybe in some money well yeah I mean
that helps I mean especially if you need
a room or you need clothes or you need
food or whatnot and I do spend my money
on those things you know I have I have a
mobile home and very live yeah I stayed
him over home I bought me a mobile home
last year and it's great it's great you
know I don't date him I'm over home or
anything like that I go get a room but
but still cuz you know I I come from a
family there you where you just don't
[ __ ] where you lay so I don't date out
of my mobile home but hey they pick me
up there yeah and they go to a hotel or
whatever yeah sometimes it mostly is car
dates oh is that right mostly it's car
dates because a lot of them a lot of the
days come between you know like 3:00 in
the morning to 6:00 in the morning
just a work time you know so a lot of
them just let me get in
out on the way to work yeah so I call
that the early morning traffic hours so
yeah those my best hours my best days is
Sunday I love Sundays I just love you
know because Sunday you get a real lot
of tension you know even the women stop
and be like girl you want to go to
church so you know I sell Sunday you
studies is really my best my best day
not not that I make a lot of money on
that day oh yeah I did I think I make
money on Sundays and I do any how much
money will you make good day well I'm
not young anymore so beautiful so
because the age you know bracket you
know understand I used to bring in like
twelve hundred a night when I was you
know 17 so whereas I'm you know 38 now I
bring in well I still keep myself with a
quarter and that quarter is five hundred
dollars I don't care I will you know
because and that's that's not including
my smoking habit so did you interested
before oh yeah I got hold cases galore
and like I told you I went to the
California Youth Authority for attempted
murder so I did some time there but it's
only been you know prostitution you know
a lot of misdemeanors and two felonies
yeah one I had a robbery with it one of
the jobs out there and I really didn't
do it but I had to take the case because
my grandmother was dying and that that
lady is the one that rescued me from
Jackson Alabama and brought me back to
California and she was like a angel to
me and so they gave her a certain time
to live so I went to court never in a
million years that I imagined the thing
was gonna come up at me with this deal
of you know you can get out today time
served you know I had been in there nine
months fighting this case and time
served
a strike and five years probation run it
you know I've been in here nine months
already fighting this case and I just
got tired of stripping and showing my
ass you know to the deputies that wasn't
giving me any money for it
you know and hey I think that's why I
don't have whole cases no more because
it's such thing it's called regulars you
know and that's why I'm always good to
adjourn I don't care who they are where
it wasn't Walker life they came from I
don't care if they rich none of that I
think as long as I get them upon mass
time they don't want to come back to me
you have that experience you know yeah
have you have got experiment yeah yeah I
mean I remember this one guy told me
because of my smile he wasn't going to
shoot me in the head with his nine
because I wouldn't suck his dick without
a condom I told him to shoot me I'm I'm
out here anyways I'm already
I'm already suicidal just do me the
favor you know and that's really the way
I felt you know and that's the way I
still feel if I if I if I just so
happened to get into a bad car because
you know it's a lot of people are just
trying to rile people in with you but
what I tell them is you know you can
take my purse you know you're just be
practicing because that's what it is I'm
nothing to carry no money in my purse
none of that you know I didn't stuck my
hope my money in the hole in the ground
just to keep it you know and I would
never forget that guy you know I was
sorry I you know I got cut by the knife
man I don't know if a lot of people
remember the knife man but the knife man
was the one that was cutting the girls
up and putting them in trash cans the
police called it a nice man well I was
one of the ones that's a nice man let go
I'm greatly appreciated for that
although it was only five of us there
was let go I'm grateful
had you been raped before and I'm sure
and stuff like that yeah you've been
raped before foul
hell yeah I was raped by my daddy I was
I was ready I was molested by my
biological father I have a baby by him I
was raped by several different men but I
feel like when I go through those
crisises sometimes I mean like before I
used to cry you know because I was with
a pimp Danny you know it just had to be
done you know I didn't want to get my
ass whooped
I didn't want to do a lot of things that
I did you know
somebody took took the virginity of my
ass which is the only thing I thought
was a virgin on me you know and I just
feel like I have nothing else left to do
but get this [ __ ] right for real you
know I remember I granny used to tell me
just to be the best at everything you do
you know at one point in time I became
homeless I was standing the tent are you
stay on Skid Row
oh really downtown yeah you stay on Skid
Row I just start putting my money up and
I said [ __ ] a parent you know I started
saying [ __ ] the pipe and I had the
courts held my habit period I went to
school before you know and I can tell
you I want to be a I wanted to own my
own trucking company one day but I had
to stop morning first can you tell me
about your experiences working with the
ten
those are some bad experiences I got
tired of being beat I've been beat with
broken water hose wet I have been
through a lot of stuff man
I'm especially with a pen up underneath
my breasts I have a scar
hmm a pimp trying to take out my heart
and he said that I was too kind to
people and he needs to cut it out and
you know
I've had some pain with hints and
I don't see how me and could do women
the way they do the way that they did me
you know one of my parents had several
other men to come in and it was 21 men
to come in one behind another
I just laid there numb I just know you
know and I don't think I'll forget and
you know that makes me not want to but
several different times maybe not one
whole anymore and I want to smoke drugs
anymore or not I mean if you could sit
in the courtroom and have your parental
rights terminated because you don't want
to stop hoeing on the track I just can't
bring myself to cure that addiction just
yeah do I think that I will one day yeah
I think I'll gain enough money to get my
trucking company
right now I just have it C self oh oh
yeah yeah you're strong yeah yeah you
know I think that I'm gonna get a great
big house and put all holes in you know
Sofia I really do
you know I date this this man he said
that he was gonna marry me but I don't
think he is you know he knows that I
have an addiction and he don't take my
money or anything he treat me as though
we're in a relationship and yeah
he's a vet and he has a lot of knowledge
and a lot of wisdom and I think there
and we've been trying to get a house and
not just a little room house because I
do trying to take hose off the street in
the near future
and when I say the near future I mean
like the next two months I'm gonna get
everybody that I can and that's where
I'm gonna start I you know I am gonna
charge them rent that's it
I don't want they money for a hold I
don't want none of that I just I want
them to
get better and I feel like if they know
my testimony and they know my struggles
it's gonna happen and by doing it for
others you're doing it for yourself
III know that my testimony is gonna save
a lot of prostitutes so that they don't
have to go I'm not getting graphic in it
and really I can probably not drunk
enough but I got some stories and I know
that my testimony in one day save Kenny
what's what's the worst thing I mean I
think that that gun story was was
horrible bit the worst thing I had
happened to me was I have somebody take
my virginity of my ass and I was brutal
to me he put a thing around my neck he
wrapped it like this I mean had me in
doggy style
and he was burning me with cigarettes
on my back I have the bruises the scars
I have all that and you know I had I had
to get 27 stitches in my anal he was
pushing pushing big deal dose and a
stick you know it's open it up more
that's right
what would you say to a young girl
going considering how much out there I
would tell them to uh excuse me sorry
I'll tell them to
keep hope alive and
there is a chance that one day if with
the right mind and with the right tools
and with the right guidance that you can
become what you want and I'm sure it
wasn't a prostitute there is a big huge
chance that if you make the willingness
to follow through with your goals
it'll happen I had anything to say to a
prostitute regardless if she was younger
oh I'll tell them you still got a chance
baby and that's what I would tell them
and the words willing a lot of hoes will
see me a lot of pimps will get to know
me because I ain't gonna stop I'm not
gonna stop and I feel like I can save
people and I'm going to it was beautiful
by fine thank you very much yeah we're
you're welcome thank you for letting me
share
thank you there's a few good speaker
[Music]
already and I haven't even been through
the day
thank you I appreciate know I appreciate
you any likable watch this
you